it is not a defense to say
because other prosecutors in other
matters at other times made different
charging decisions after other
investigations related to other possible
charges
that has nothing to do with Trump
Hillary Clinton was accused of being
extremely careless in her handling of
classified information she was not
accused of intentionally disclosing
information there is no evidence she
lied to investigators she cooperated and
handed over tens of thousands of emails
etc etc
Trump is accused of willfully risking
National Security secrets and conspiring
with lawyers and others to conceal
documents and make false statements he
did not cooperate with the investigation
he hid the documents for months at his
house in boxes near his toilet so the
situations aren't actually analogous